okay we just got done seeing a
documentary called
was it they shall not grow old yeah and
it's a World War one documentary about
World War one combat and the the footage
is all like restored and colorized they
even like lip-read then we did like
lip-reading on the the guys that are
shown in the combat footage and
reenacted what they were saying it was a
pretty good documentary yeah done by
Peter Jackson you shootin no it was very
interested in World War one yeah served
in World War one and so this is kind of
like it's kind of cool like what they
did they took you know all of these
hours of footage from the first world
war which of course was black and white
and silent like I said they had it sound
they added color and he kind of did it
the way I made kitchen your mother was
like a huge topic yeah but I like the
way they approached it where he kind of
she was just like well I wanted to take
like the general experience yeah for
like infantry infantry like a soldier
what they would have experienced like
from when they joined up to you know all
the way through the war and like what
happened yeah the four years because he
said it he thought that that was
probably you know fairly generic generic
in the right of way that like other
soldiers probably experienced the same
thing no matter what country they were
fighting in or frightening or rather I
also like that they um that they you
know the it was it was a good
documentary wasn't really historical in
terms of like they weren't telling you
know giving you the years and what the
specific battles happened when it's not
really that kind of a documentary it's
more like just a kind of an homage of
what what combat was like for your
average guy it was a ton likes it
because it was actually kind of it
wasn't like that and he
and there was like a little documentary
like another sub documentary like yeah
the credits and like he's kind of
explaining how they restored the footage
and like what he wanted to do with it
and I like what he's like I didn't want
this to be like an academic or like a
historical site because she can kind of
get that anywhere he's like I wanted
this to be like humanized so it's like a
personal experience you can like
actually feel what it was like the
people that were there Oh what I was
gonna say was I like that well the only
voiceovers that they have were veterans
yeah we're actually there that we're
actually on the western part they don't
have any like historians talking they
don't have any reenactment and recording
to the guys have actually recordings of
the guys ever actually interviews and it
was just like kind of cut together all
through the whole thing and they were
talking about their personal experiences
and stuff like that and and it was kind
of like I said cut together all these
different voices like in a way that sort
of made it like a narrative yeah I mean
but yeah I thought it was amazing yeah
for me you know other than the other
than the actual quality of the footage
and you know the colorization process
and for me it wasn't all that surprising
you know being xfg myself and no one
what you know cuz that you know and a
lot about World War one so for me it
wasn't really anything new but it was
good to see ya I mean and honestly like
a lot of the most interesting stuff I
thought was just kind of like the guys
talking about lights just their
day-to-day yeah what their day-to-day
stuff was like once when they joined up
and like what it was like like being in
the trenches with nothing what's
happening and yeah what I would like to
get out and go home yeah a lot of these
are just universal so I mean that's
that's just the way it is you come out
of like a hard service background like
that you know you go back to civilian
life you are a different species they
tied one of them actually yeah perfused
almost those exact words actually but
yeah I liked so I liked that that kind
of aspect of it really like human yes
the entire experience they came back
from the war nobody wanted to hire them
and stuff like anyone I'm around nobody
understood him yeah
we'll say that may not seem like these
Parkinson seen I mean these is like a
lot of them were real it we're very
young when they do that because they
weren't real you know there's a lot more
15 16 years old yeah there was like
teenagers yeah I mean then they were
seeing people to get yeah but yeah I
really um it's weird because it's kind
of like spotty the way they're showing
it it's like they showed it like once or
twice a week like for the past yeah
we've who's we've been trying to see it
like for the last few weeks but they're
always like most time it's not shown him
then yeah and they'll show it like one
time like in a weird day today yeah it
was it was a good movie I really meant a
lot I could all day actually yeah
you
okay just got done seeing one called
destroyer that was Nicole Kidman right
yes yeah and it was I think I'd call
this film noir huh kind of like a kind
of a modern yeah about a federal agent
female federal agent that picks up a
know who who left the FBI to become I
think she worked for LAPD yeah and yeah
and working for the LAPD she picks up an
old case that that caused her to leave
the FBI she finally kind of wrap up
loose ends it was going every guy who
killed her partner yeah and then
whatever undercover when they were
undercover yeah and as the whole story
unfolds you find out more and more about
this partner in the situation they had
you know back then and she's almost kind
of a bad cop really in a way yes she's a
very yeah yeah and I don't know it was
uh the acting was pretty good it was
kind of a well filmed movie with shot
well had really good music very like
shitty and crappy locations which kind
of fit the story lie you know like it
didn't really yeah asti drug houses and
Guzzi shit-ton of the movie very
negative very down but I actually really
liked it I have read a good you'd like
it I had been wanting to see this
because check this out this movie
started like we've been seeing trailers
for like months ago yeah and it was
supposed to start in December but we
didn't get it yeah they were out of here
this week and then suddenly finally
started playing now I should know that
was just that this was directed by karen
Kusama who also directed girl fight
which I haven't seen
but she also directed a movie called the
invitation which i think is still on
netflix and go check that [ __ ] out
because that movies amazing it's like a
horror movie so this one if you like
that movie I think you would like this
one it's it's a different genre kind
it's not really a horror movie but I
think it's know are yeah or it's kind of
like like a modern-day like a yeah
Friday like there were so more certain
part aspects that movie kind of reminded
me of the very original Blade Runner at
certain times yeah but instead in today
in modern days and going back into the
90s because there's a lot of flashbacks
yeah it's like I think there was like a
15 or 16 year gap because they show her
like when she was younger if you've seen
the trailers they made her look like a
Hell on toast man because do it not only
is she like supposed to be 15 16 years
older but she's also kind of a drunk and
she's like you know bad health
yeah and [ __ ] like that so they made her
look like super shitty like in the
present day but then they show her
younger like when she was undercover
like that a long time ago so like the
way it was structured because you know
they kind of went back and forth between
the past and you like the present um
where it's like you know they'd have a
scene in the present then it would show
like the past thing so they were like
commenting on it you know what I mean
she likes that kinda stuff I don't like
those stories structures I like to be
very linear
that was one things kind of bothered me
except sometimes losing track of what
was supposed to be having in the present
was supposed to be in the past I thought
that guy was dead oh okay this is a
flashback oh they like I said I didn't
really have that much trouble because
some two people look so much older yeah
and different that you could tell
immediately like especially when they
showed once with her because she
obviously looked a lot different
not a bad movie not my cup of tea I
really wouldn't recommend it if you want
to have a good time I thought well yeah
like I said it's not a good yeah it's
good yeah it's gonna make you feel bad
yeah I liked I really liked it though I
kind of liked movies that kind of are
escapist this one will not let you
escape this one is
today this one just punches you with you
it was a great like it but like you know
like I said I don't like that sometimes
- yes alright I really like
you
okay we just got done seeing the prodigy
yes which was a horror movie I thought
it was gonna be kind of a psychological
horror movie you know kind of like that
stared typical bad kid movie and it
kinda was but then as the movie goes on
you find out that that's not really what
it's about
yeah I was gonna say almost reminded me
but I better not no way to give it away
let's just say that there it has a
paranormal element to it
yeah it's you're gonna see elements from
some really classic movies yeah I save
like like I said one in particular but
I'm not gonna mention chance ese cuz I
don't want want to steal a movie Stuber
yeah had a good had a tight story it's
pretty good shot well acting was good
real good excellent whoever scored this
movie was great had really good I feel
like this yeah it has a really good
really feel like atmospherically just
creating like imagery if that kid was
creepy as [ __ ] yeah he did good job he
really did like you could totally buy
that he was like totally innocent to it
the theater but also previous like yeah
the whole whole movie I would say well
above average I actually liked it a lot
I really enjoyed it I thought it was
like really like I said it had a really
good like tense atmosphere yeah weren't
really sure like I said I just thought
it was like you I just thought it was
like some Tuzla bad kid movie yeah it
kind of is but it kind of has more
toilet about yeah and then they
definitely didn't wrap it up totally I
mean you know it's wide open for a seat
book they wanted it yeah yeah story's
not done yeah but yeah and it's almost
kind of like it's trying to establish a
the story and or a series is what it
looks like
yes I think you could really do that
maybe no I good thing is I feel like a
lot of movies do that now like just in
case rough like they do really well and
like somebody come the only thing that I
could probably criticize the movie for
is that the ending didn't have a big
climactic ending it had an ending but it
wasn't a big climactic ending like that
like I kind of like you know with it
with the ain't with you know my eighties
background I like you too might kill the
monster two or three times it comes back
and I was not done that comes back again
and you book I have like some [ __ ] like
that
but I was still good yes it's kind of a
highbrow movie in a wink yeah it well
it's not well we're not talking you know
tall tree guys you're not talking
chuckles kind of highbrow for the genre
everything if you're talking along the
lines of Exorcist an evil horror no the
old man here yes I would I'm putting it
in that it was very similar to the jet
it gave me that kind of vibe like that
classic like seventies horror movie kind
of vibe even though it wasn't you didn't
look like a movie set back then
necessarily it didn't it's not shot that
way it's not shot that way it wasn't set
back then but for some reason just the
way it was structured yeah you know the
storyline stuff like that reminded me
reminiscent of those of movies from that
era which I like you know it yeah you
guys watch the show you know the 70s and
early 80s is like my favorite yeah you
know my favor
time period for horror movies and this
reminded me very strongly I do a lot of
the best ones from then yeah so you know
I recommend it yeah you can see like of
course this you check it out and
especially if you like evil kid movies
yeah yeah it's true